welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to season five of black mirror has
just dropped on Netflix and the new show
has a hell of a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down smithereens starring Andrew Scott
and giving my thoughts on the meaning
behind its ending this is full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't seen the show
yet and don't want anything room for
yourself then I highly recommend that
you turn up now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for click
in this video I hope you enjoy it now
sit back relax and let's get into my
ending explain breakdown of smithereens
smithereens is the only British episode
of season 5 and from the off it's pretty
nihilistic just as a sidetrack I mean is
it me or are all the British episodes of
black mirror way better than the
American ones I'm not being racist yet
but there's just something about being
British that's instantly depressing it's
kind of hard for me to feel sorry for
Miley Cyrus when she's living it up in
LA sunshine while I'm stuck in the
pissin rain watching Netflix through
someone's window feeding my kids maggots
from McDonald's cuz that's all we kind
of bored after brexit sorry about that
anyway we join Andrew Scott who plays a
man named Chris a taxi driver that finds
himself orchestrating an attempt to take
down social media once and for all
Chris is kidnapped in intend of a social
company named smithereen and he is
threatening to kill the man if he isn't
connected to the company CEO Billy power
throughout the 70 minute thrill ride we
learn of Chris's past and what drove him
to do the things that he did and it's
clear that this episode is a comment on
how in being connected to everyone
digitally we have become disconnected
physically the lost art of conversation
is present throughout and Chris just
wants to return to a simpler time when
things weren't all about likes comments
and shares and while on the subject yeah
make sure you like comment and share
this video cheese yeah anyway no matter
what kind of relationship Chris tries to
build he's blocked by his screen whether
it's a grieving mother or simply a woman
that he is
picking up from a meeting at smithereen
everyone seems transfixed by a screen
desperately searching for a connection
that they could have with Chris if they
simply paid attention to him many
hypothesize including the negotiator
that this is the reason why wants to
reach the CEO after being ignored for so
long and just catching the attention of
the CEO of a major company that everyone
else looks up to will give his life
justification and make him feel like
everyone is looking at him they think
that deep down Chris wants attention
just as much as those constantly posting
to social media - he is however willing
to go to the extreme for it though the
true reason begins to emerge during the
rise in situation after being chased by
police Chris runs off-road and becomes
stuck which is where the majority of the
episode takes place due to his wonder
man and hostage this becomes an
international incident with the FBI and
US forces all working together to try
and save Chris's hostage Jayden however
everything is not as it seems and Chris
finally gets in touch with Billy Bauer
after the creator and axe guard mode to
speak directly to him it's from here we
discover the real reason why the entire
ordeal has taken place we learn that
Chris and his fiance were both social
media Alex
Chris was obsessed with the platform and
after driving home one night he became
distracted by a notification and crashed
the car killing the other driver and
eventually his wife Chris avoided all
blame as the other driver was drunk but
that doesn't mean he doesn't carry the
guilt Chris and probably the audience
are heartbroken by the entire ordeal and
the confession needs Chris to plead that
the addictiveness has taken out the apps
Billy too confesses that he's created a
monster in the app that is purely there
to drive dopamine hits similar to Chris
he doesn't know how to slop everything
and his to share a moment before Chris
finally breaks Billy's admission saying
that he was simply stating his piece the
only thing he wants is for the grieving
mother he slept with to have access to
her daughter's account and after getting
this he hangs up the phone overall it's
really gripping stuff and both Adam
Scott and Topher Grace completely knock
it out of the park
with his back and forth phone call that
is probably the highlight of the season
Chris states he wants to let jaden go
but he refuses after realizing that
chris will kill himself as soon as he
leaves the to engage in his struggle
that ends with a sniper taking a fatal
shot which ends the episode though we
don't see which of the two were killed
just the public's reaction to it so
which one was it well whilst this could
have been a somewhat happy ending with
Chris dying this is black mirror and the
nonchalant attitude of the public
towards the barely reported on Jayden
makes me believe that it was him that
ended up in the firing line
had it been Chris people would have no
doubt pulled out their phones and began
spraying their thoughts all over social
media however as they don't it is likely
that Jayden died and this is also
enforced by the fact that Billy returns
to meditating the character has no
connection with Jayden only Chris and
nurses death is just a statistic overall
this is probably my favorite episode of
season 5 with it both blaming
individuals for continuing their
addiction as well as the corporations
that prey upon this chris acknowledges
he caused the car accident but also
blames the corporation for causing his
addiction and this metaphorically can be
aligned with alcohol drugs and more as
things that we know are dangerous but
are thrust upon us as something that we
need in our lives to enjoy ourselves in
the end the outcome of the situation
doesn't really matter just in the same
way that it doesn't really matter to the
public our lives
similar to Chris and Jaden's have become
reduced notifications that we see to get
a hit of dopamine and turn off until we
get the next one this is the true
meaning of the episode and ultimately
Billy closing his eyes once more in the
final shot represents our blindness to
just how disposable that we have become
because of it he and his company are
shutting themselves off to the damage
that they are doing and are continuing
to prey on the populace ultimately this
episode stuck with me long after I left
it and that's why it gets an 8 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and what you took from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of striking vipers would you be linked
at the end this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again potato
to watch this you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]